When I go to share
something, it's
probably because I had a
fleeting thought about how
cool it was, which
means that if it takes
too long to actually share, I'm
going to hit the Back button
and give up.
I'm Joanna Smith, and I am
your least favorite user.
To help you create magic
moments when sharing,
Android Marshmallow
introduced a new feature
called Direct Share.
With Direct Share, you can
define direct share targets
that launch a specific
activity in your app
when the user initiates a share.
To be clear here,
consider the current flow.
If I found a fun new
article to show my sister,
and I select your app
from the Share dialog,
your app launches.
That's great.
But a direct share means that
I can select my conversation
with my sister,
and your app opens
to that conversation with
the article already waiting
in the message text
view for me to hit Send.
Now that is a good
user experience.
To enable direct
share targets, you
must define a class that extends
from ChooserTargetService,
and in this new
service of yours,
you need to implement
onGetChooserTargets.
This method is the one that
will offer up those share
targets to the system so that it
may populate the Share dialog.
OnGetChooserTargets is where
your app can get as fancy
as its little heart desires.
Maybe it makes the most
sense to offer up the 10 most
recent conversations, or
perhaps your app offers a way
for users to track who
they care the most about,
and you can provide a list
of those BFFs instead.
Or maybe you know
which conversations,
like group messages,
for example,
are most prone to
using attachments,
and those are your
likely share targets.
This magic is up to you.
We just made the
framework so that you
could build a better app.
Now we need to
update our manifest.
As with any new service,
we need to declare it,
but what is special
about our declaration is
the BIND_CHOOSER_TARGET_SERVICE
permission.
This will let us
interact with the system
to exchange those
implicit intents and share
targets properly.
Oh, and of course, the
intent filter that associates
this service as a
chooser target service.
That covers everything you need
to populate the system share
dialog, but what about
when the user selects
one of your options?
You'll want to start the proper
activity when your app is
launched, and to
do that, you need
to tie those specific activities
to the correct implicit intent.
So you'll need some
metadata to do this,
but it really is
as simple as that.
So to play with Direct
Share in your own app,
take a look at our
super fun sample, which
is linked in the
description below,
or check out our documentation.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]